thank you thank you thank you
so my name is jung jung boom s dad said
I'm living in Amsterdam I'm working in
Norway I'm traveling to Asia all the
time I mean I I feel right at home here
with all these nomads that also travel
the world it's beautiful
so Telenor is a telecom that pays me to
work on Mozilla stuff and half my time
I'm currently dedicating on the Firefox
West project and working on keyboard and
stuff like that another thing is you
guys are all like the creme de la creme
of JavaScript you guys know everything
about Firefox OS so today we're going to
do something way way way more fun first
thing I need to say is that I'm also
writing a book about Firefox OS my
editor asked me to do that and when I
first signed a book deal
I designed my own cover because they
didn't have it ready for some reason
they didn't go for this at Manning so
now it looks like this so if you're
interested in doing Firefox OS
development do you want to know
everything about like how we can make
cool mobile web applications that look
pretty and stuff like that go here on my
Twitter there's like a discount code and
all that stuff now as half the
presenters here at JS cons I'm going to
start with a confession because the
moment that I send in my talk proposal I
did not own a screwdriver and this is
the worst worst way to get started on a
hardware talk so - so two weeks ago
I basically ate everything up and
running but all all my demos were still
basically a mobile phone so I had to
dissect this and I think the result was
wonderful and a lesson learned there is
that if I can do this
without ever owning a screwdriver then
you guys can do it too you guys can
build cool stuff with the things you
learn today in this presentation
am i my timer is not running that the
maker movement is at the moment
everywhere I was in Malaysia and and
some random guy walks up to me he says
hey Yan we got like this great maker
space where you can like hack on stuff
please come down there and go fiddle
with us and like that's so cool we're
actually building stuff that like
augments the world around this right now
and the reason that we can do that is
because these new nice little
development boards for example a test
hole that we saw yesterday in north
disco they're here they're very cheap
microcontrollers computers have become
so fast that they can be very tiny and
do all kinds of cool stuff the second
thing is that you can attach phone
sensors to this this whole explosion of
smartphones makes that having sensors
that control your accelerometer or
gravity or small cameras have become
very very cheap you can attach them now
it is always a downside because this is
how an average Raspberry Pi Arduino
board looks like and for me as a
software guy this is way way way to
complicate it you know I can't stick I
can't stick things in like little you
know and on top of that like so much is
hardware that you can attach to your s
provides very expensive why do I have to
pay 35 euros for a TFT screen for
Raspberry Pi well it can get a full
Firefox OS phone for 25 including
battery chips everything so figured hey
1 + 1 is 2 so I I took one of my phone's
gigs from peak Developer Preview device
that basically has Bluetooth Wi-Fi 3G
these has two cameras it's a little bit
more expensive than 25 euros but not
that much and I figured if I can't abuse
debts to do my Internet of Things things
then it don't need to solder anything I
don't need to connect any external
things anyway cheaper then if you on set
and on top of this it runs Firefox OS
you might think why is that
cool well firefox has basically works
like this I got a phone I got a Linux
kernel then I have gecko the render
engine that powers Mozilla Firefox on
top of that and then html5 UI that means
that every piece of UI on the phone
needs to go through gecko that means
that every API that does cool functions
is included in gecko so if I strip off
the html5 UI then it got like a phone
super cheap phone with JavaScript
bindings to everything this is perfect
for hackers so awesome this is what you
this is what you get if you search for
awesome kids on Google and ok so
basically is how you start you take a
Firefox OS phone
then you'll unscrew it then you use your
newly acquired screwdriver to crack it
open and then you'll end up with this
and this is very tiny print board that
controls everything on your phone I got
one here you can't even see it from the
back it's this tiny this contains all
your sensors it contains two cameras SIM
card slot everything everything
everything that's amazing very small so
we got a SIM card reader SD card reader
here the the screen connector one camera
there's also one on the front
flashlights and touch screen connector
these are all things it just click them
just plug and play don't need screen
just disconnect the screen and I also
found out something that the camera is
very easily detached because it fell out
what Wow
but then I found something wonderful
because these cameras have a standard
connector you can just go to China and
buy a better camera for your phone and
the only problem is basically it doesn't
fit in your print boards but as we're
not needing it to fit in a phone anyway
we can just buy a new camera and like
attach that blue in mind yes
then there's at the bottom of the phone
there's also something and this is
connected to the screen and I don't know
what it is
I ripped it apart and it still worked so
so basically you end up with this you
got a print board the the thing at the
rights or at the left for you at the
left is it does like radio communication
it's like an antenna extension that you
plug into the print board if you want to
do something with data over 3G or you
want to make phone calls then connect
that and you'll end up with the casing
in the casing has a touchscreen and a
normal screen and I figured I I want I
want those two separate as well now the
thing is at cheap smartphones these
things are glued together and I tried a
screwdriver to unglue these so first it
broke then it's correct and then I
figured I can just like only detach the
touchscreen and this is the touchscreen
connector so I use my screwdriver again
and that didn't work out that well
either
so the demos that you're going to see
today do not involve a screen um so then
we got this little print board but then
Wi-Fi doesn't work and and that really
puzzled me so I figured like the radio
chip has something to do with it or
anything and then I saw these connectors
at the Etsy back cover of your phone and
is they look like paper with like a
little copper plating and this little
thing if you attach it to your phone
with a little tape you'll actually go
from zero Wi-Fi network in your range
like 12 here this is like I've still
puzzled how this works
I'm stem cell software guy here but you
know this is like real real type for
your hardware solutions and it's
freaking small it's three choirs of of a
credit card uh you know in all fairness
I I first put the credit card next to to
the thing and and only five minutes
before my talk I realize you could all
see my credit card number
and so what we now have is like the
little board we got gecko running on top
of that and now we can build something
cool and tell us that you know so I call
this because I don't have a problem with
anything or so Yano s yes it's the
unofficial logo yellow s is an
alternative to Firefox OS you can run it
on any route that's Firefox OS phone
that you just buy in the store and it's
especially made to run on this chip
board so no screen there's no
touchscreen input there's no UI there's
nothing basically gives you a JavaScript
console you can program anything you
want with them and some batteries are
included so we'll auto connect to 3G
networks if you put a sim card in an APN
detection and stuff like that and I made
another mistake so I broke I broke the
casing of my phone while I was trying to
fiddle with the touchscreen and that
means that every time I have to boot it
you need two batteries I have to press
the print port and a battery together
and then like with one hand to disk and
then go to my computer and type the
flash command and then do enter that's
the only way I can upgrade the thing so
please keep your back cover intact
because that everything fits together
nicely it makes it a lot easier to flash
and now yan OS is very easy it's name
it's an HTML file we we have gak up when
we just render one HTML file in it and
that has JavaScript and you can do
device stuff with that easy PC now the
cool thing is that you can also be
connect the Firefox developer tools to
this phone so if you want a JavaScript
debugger of your stuff then use the use
of normal Firefox the debugger that's
really powerful you get me to show you
that in a second and there's a bunch of
things you can now do with this little
print board for example make a security
camera let's just take a photo every 5
seconds then see if something really
changed
if so make a photo send it to me over
over MMS or over email maybe if
something really shake is going on you
can actually call because you can put a
sim card in it it's amazing stuff plus
my little print but even it's four
gigabytes of storage already included so
if you want to do that seven lines of
code it's it's just like camera take
picture front
it's a promise it resolves you get a
blob then you get a reference to the
picture storage that can be on the SD
card or on the internal storage
depending what you haven't found and
then say storage add names to that done
easy another one a doorbell you know
like I bought a wireless doorbell
recently it was more expensive than the
phone and it's not Wireless at all I
still have to push a button in front of
my door at my door post so I figured if
we use the phone there we can do it's
really wireless because the phone is a
proximity sensor so you can like wave my
door post and it will play over
Bluetooth in my living room I mean this
is like this cool and plus it has a
front camera next to the proximity
sensors you can even like include a
video stream this little board is
cheaper than any of those doorbells with
video screens that you can ever buy also
doing this is eight lines I can connect
to any Bluetooth audio device I just
have to have the ID of it and then when
and a known user proximity if the user
is near its users within 10 or 15
centimeters of proximity sensor then
play a sound and will automatically play
over bluetooth instead of over built-in
speakers last example that I have this
is Maya this is me my friend my group of
friends and in the middle is he a pretty
rad boy with a cigarette his name is
brian and brian has a very annoying
tendency he gets lost a lot he may even
we were in Warsaw and and Brian didn't
find the apartment back at 5 a.m. so he
slept on a little bench on a square I've
been told
this came and he had to be friends with
a bum because the bum knew like a
telecom shop where he could charge his
phone but because his phone is also
always that so I figured the Brian
tracker and I could take the board solar
battery to it have a 2g connection
because of the SIM card and whenever
Brian is lost I can send a push
notification over 2g it will tell me the
geolocation and tada
let's go mmm here's the cool thing
because at a screen it's basically
eating most of your battery time so this
solution will run about two weeks on the
default battery without even charging it
this is pretty amazing you can like
build actual useful stuff with this
little board and I bring through the
next thing let's do some demos this was
me at the after party yesterday by the
way so we have what I have here is what
are the boards that are removed from one
of the phones and now I can connect to
this and now I have a zoom in and now
basically the JavaScript console that I
can talk to and do device things with
for example if I want to read the device
motion because this thing also is the
accelerometer in it for example I now
get like the horizontal acceleration
including gravity and here's cool if I
turn it around gets into the minus
and okay so it's pretty cool now now I
found a new problem and if you do
something on this board that draws too
much power like connecting to Wi-Fi you
don't have a battery attached then it
will just shut down and I think if you
want wire like two of the wires then
then you can probably solve that but
you've all seen what happens when I try
to Deacon echt the screen so I don't
trust myself like soldering stuff
actually so for that I have a second
thing it's indicating so I can hold the
battery with it
and it also SIM card and I'm going to
connect this now
so we can connect here's well we're
little too big okay um so there's a SIM
card in here and as you can see it
detects that the SIM card is there and
automatically enable data for me over 3G
or 2g and this is a very powerful
feature because you can and it almost is
now that it does not eat any data unless
you tell it to so you can just buy a
prepaid SIM card while you can't really
buy it in Germany because you need to
like live here and like having address
and and give up your mom and your first
birth rights to get a SIM card as I've
experienced but with my Dutch same card
actually works and for example I can now
do simple xhr calls okay so it works for
example we have two security cam feature
so let me demonstrate that so I can tell
it to read the back camera and do it
every five seconds three seconds and now
this holes like this and we'll take a
photo every three seconds okay so let
three photos and I can stop it again and
now it's a fit to the internal storage
and because it's basically Linux running
on this thing I can it's basically based
on the Android kernel I can do a to be
pool stuff out of the cards yeah yeah
I did not promise the images would be
sharp so you can't get me on that
um the other demo and what I brought
today tonight so the sound people put
this like here very carefully Bluetooth
speaker and now I'm going to talk to
bluetooth to start doorbell start it
again
so it fans the thing and out goes
automatically pair and now when I hover
over the proximity sensor it will start
playing doorbell that's Fitz if it's off
I remove it
okay um it also has Wi-Fi built-in and
now I hope that my tape Holtz because I
I want to do tracking and stuff and for
that you need Wi-Fi connection or makes
it better if you do it indoors so enable
Wi-Fi so it tries to attempt to connect
to JazzFest I hope that's going to work
my mom always told me to never do any
you know it did not work my mom always
told me to never do any live demos but
here we go actually wife is now
connected to JazzFest we only need an IP
address here we are so now we have a
Wi-Fi connection is cool disable this
and now we can start my tracker so let's
say that I'm Brian and at this moment I
am lost okay this is the Brian tracker
at this moment there is no registration
yet but if I tell tracker will start it
will register at the bush server that
Mozilla has and now we're here the only
problem is that we don't have any
location from Brian yeah so all we need
to do is in this case check request new
location now the phone in a couple
seconds will receive a push message and
based on that yeah it's going to like
use the geolocation API to find out
where we are at this moment and then
communicate that back so we got a push
message we oughta grant permissions
because permissions are for suckers you
know I mean this my device you can do
anything and we send our location and
now a couple seconds later I guess I
found out you guys all use Google Maps
static maps we were blocked here but
when I click on it we get redirected to
Google Maps and we find out where we are
and now I'm going to be back to my slide
now there's so much more that you can do
with this setup if you because there's a
flashlight on this thing I mean two
cameras you can like walk around they
like make photos on this side and on
this side but the only way to really
experience is and this is what I've seen
like like so much is get hacking you
know by a root full Firefox West phone
if you're here in Germany then the ZTE
open CD seen the left is your best bet
you can get it for 60 euros and eBay
crack it open
flash my nos thing on it and and just
write your own scripts you know you you
are in charge you can build Internet of
Things things even if you're not a
hardcore nerd and I think that's that's
freaking amazing and with that I want to
thank you all for being here and
hopefully see you next year
yes
you